voilà pour la réaction des jeunes de
l'ump et du mjs
avant d'entendre notre invité vincent
peillon je vous propose de découvrir
d'autres réactions celle dans l'ordre de
françois bayrou pour le modem marine le
pen pour le front national et jean luc
mélenchon pour le front de gauche pas eu
un mot sur l'éducation
il n'y a pas eu non plus un mot sur
l'environnement il n'y a pas eu une
stratégie crédible pour remettre delà de
la production en france et de ce point
de vue là j'avais l'air enfin j'ai eu
l'impression qu'il ne répondait pas du
tout qui n'était pas sur le même plan
que les français quand ils expriment
leur inquiétude ce soir le sarkozysme
est mort et c'est là la grande victoire
du chiraquisme
que ce soit dans la ford capri
car oui le remaniement où l'on revoit
beaucoup de chirac 1 c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire ce que les
villepinistes sont aussi chiraquien que
je sois dans cette posture assez
inquiétante faite de constats et aida
d'un aveu d'impuissance incroyable que
ça va être une fin de quinquennat
totalement engagé dans un
gouvernement de castagne pour lui il a
tourné la page de la sphère des
retraites ce que les gens souffert et
endurer la pas eu un amour pour penser à
tous ceux qui ont perdu des journées de
salaire pour défendre leurs idées tout
ça là ni faire là la réalité humaine a
l'air très éloigné de lui